The prophet Muhammad sallallah.aii
wasallam told us that whoever builds a
mosque for Allah, Allah will build for
him a sim at a house in Jenna. And we
know the great reward that will not only
be gained but rather will fill your
grave after your death. Whenever someone
prays there, whenever someone gives
shahada in the masid, whenever someone
learns something in the masid, yes, that
will be something that you'll have on
your scale.
[Music]
How are you guys doing? I'm joined with
the two main men. A man to my far left
who's he looks like a scanger.
I'm only kidding. Is a man who's known
to the people now for being I would say,
you know, one of the top guys in current
affairs. What did you say? One of the
top comedians in the DA.
>> Comedian.
>> Oh, only also his dais. You know, he's
my teacher now.
>> Of course. He's always been stuff now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Speaker's corn now. He's
trying to take position.
>> Who going to speak now?
>> You did it.
>> Did you do it?
>> Yeah.
>> No way.
>> You're going that big biceps.
>> He got He got biceps. No.
>> No. But who told him to train?
>> You told him to.
>> Ah. When he looks so smart and sexy like
that, you
>> What have you been doing?
>> Nothing. Nothing. You puny man. Well,
>> why is it not coming off? Lefty, loosey,
righty tighty. Carry carry on with
>> um I've got a fight coming up on uh
Saturday.
>> Yeah. Nobody Nobody Nobody
>> want to Nobody wants
>> wants to see me in action.
>> Yes.
>> October the 11th pay-per-view will be on
the uh description box below if you want
to get involved in something like that.
>> October 11th.
>> October the 11th.
>> Why didn't make October the 7th?
>> No, that would have been too much. I
mean, no, it's it's, you know, I mean,
they would have said things if it was
that
>> Why did they say?
>> Oh, they they would have accused us of
like I don't know, like if terrorism or
something, I don't know.
>> Oh, why? Why? Oh,
>> October the 7th.
>> Okay. I forgot about that. Yeah.
>> You know, because there's October the
6th, there's October the 5th, there's
October the 4th, there's October.
>> I was actually born on October 5th. You
know, really
>> I was born.
>> Was it your birthday?
>> Yeah, it was. I'm uh 34 now.
>> Can I say happy birthday?
>> Don't say that. Okay, we'll take that.
>> This is uh not something I'm going to
get into right now.
>> Don't get into cuz
>> But what we are going to get into
>> is a discussion
uh with Katie Hopkins that she had with
this white man and she was saying
something to him.
>> She's calling for the she's calling for
the crusades.
>> Let's take a look at this and come back
and respond in kind. And demographically
because we are already overrun.
Power sits with the Muslim religion.
Power sits with Muslim leaders.
>> Are you done?
>> And the government.
>> Is the nation done?
>> You know, I'll never say we're done
because we're still here fighting.
>> I believe there will come a time not too
far from now when the British people,
true British people, will have to make
very difficult choices.
either they will flee eastwards to
Eastern Europe with our much more
stronger Christian neighbors, Poland,
Hungary, um those countries or they will
seek asylum, flee, try to come to
America or they will stand their ground.
But certainly the time of the Crusades
will need to come again if we are to
return.
>> What do you mean by that?
>> We are overrun in every way, in every
sense. Demographically all births u
Muslim births outnumber births to every
and all other religion. This is no
commentary on anyone's religion. I'm
just this is just pure fact. Our mayors
who control funding in our capital
cities are Muslim. Mosques are not
churches. A mosque is being built at the
outermost tippy tippy most end of
Scotland and at the further most reaches
at the end of the other side of our tiny
country. This is about a takeover and of
course America understands because you
have Minneapolis because you have
Dearborn Michigan and I see it all the
time.
>> First of all, Hungary I think is more
central Europe
not Eastern uh Europe. I would say
Poland is kind of going there.
>> Uh po Poland's inter interesting because
they've been complaining that you've got
all these Poles coming over here and you
know
>> doing building work and plumbing work
and everything. It'll be interesting
jobs. It'll be interesting to see what
the British people do when they go to
Poland and what contribution they can
make to Poland other than, you know, um
>> have a pineal lago.
>> Yeah. And uh just
>> just before we continue, uh I just want
to play this advert. Uh there might I
don't think there's any connection. It's
a church that's being sold. Um so uh
because there's not that many people
going to this church.
Are you going to blame this on Muslims
as well? You guys have control. Yeah.
All you need to do is stop going after
the Muslims and start going after the
Christians. All you need to do is start
being more convincing with your
propagation.
It's not our fault that you've got the
Protestant Bible with 66 books, then
Catholic Bible with 73 books, then
you've got the the Russian Orthodox with
79 and Ethiopian with uh 81 books. Did
we do those? Did we tell your church
fathers the first 300 years to be
subordinists? Whether it's Tatulian,
whether it's origin,
>> whether it's Justin Martr, for the first
300 years. I mean, even before this
video, we were discussing when did you
even have your Bible finalized? It took
about 360 years. It needed Athanasius.
>> Which Bible?
>> Well, exactly. Which which Bible are you
referring to? Or which version of the
Trinity? Is it the version of the
Trinity where the Holy Spirit proceeds
from the Father or where the Holy Spirit
proceeds from the Father and the Son?
You've literally got the Christian world
divided 50/50 believing one thing, the
other believing the other thing. Are we
telling you, you guys, to be
homosexuals, to be boss babes, and not
give priority to getting married? Are we
literally stopping there? You know, are
we that contraception that you guys need
that is 100% effective more than
condoms? I mean, we have to be a bit
realistic over here. If you give dawa,
you guys sort out and you go to the
early understanding of Christianity, the
one that believes there is one God and
that Jesus is a prophet rather than 100%
man, 100% God. He's God, but then he
died on the cross as person, but that
one person has two natures and this
nature died. It's too complicated. It
doesn't make sense. People just are
confused. It's not our fault. You There
comes a time where you have to take
responsibility.
You guys are the majority. You guys have
churches everywhere that get funded. You
guys have spaces on the House of Lords
where there are Christian executives
that have not been elected. You don't
have imams in those positions. You don't
have
these pundits and all of these guys.
It's your people. And it's about time
you guys take responsibility for your
actions and stop moaning.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, you could have said it better.
Maybe I should end there, but I'm just
going to add a little
>> few things here. Like you said, you're
talking about theology. This woman, Kate
Hopkins, I bet she doesn't even know
what the trinity means.
>> She's just like a cultural Christian.
Like Richard Dawkins said, "We can be
cultural Christians." Yeah. Even like
Toby Robinson. You You have no idea
about Christianity. You can't follow in
Christianity. You have to shut up in the
church. Yes. Your husband has the law.
You're not allowed to talk. Okay. So,
you're not ready to follow that. Don't
come to me with Christianity and
crusades and this that. What are you
talking about crusades? You don't know
nothing about religion. You are you're
probably a promiscuous woman.
>> Actually, yeah, she
>> This woman is a promiscuous woman. She
sleeps around. She sleeps. Look, she
sleeps around. You're talking about
>> She admits it, doesn't it? Confess.
>> If the crusades were here, they would
have your head.
>> Yes. They would they would take your
head. Look, let me tell you something.
They would finish you up because
according to scripture, you are a woman
who is promiscuous. Okay? And so much
so, I mean, your scripture says if a man
happens to rape you and he decides to
pay 50 shekels to your father and you
belong to him,
>> 50
shekel herself,
>> the verse says a young girl, but she's
not young. She's extremely old. 50
shekels. I think she's in her 60s. Yeah.
Okay. So, don't talk to us.
>> It wouldn't be 50 shekels. It'll be 0.5
shekel.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So the thing is now with
the reason she to go away.
>> Exactly. Exactly. So the thing is here
is that you're here complaining about
this. You don't even follow
Christianity. You are don't like you
said don't blame us. You're not going to
church. Why is it every time due to your
neglect of your religion whatever you
blame us. Pedophilia is your issue. You
attack us. Yes. You don't go to the
church church to be turned into mosques.
You blame us. You don't go pray and
birth rates are falling. You're not
you're having intimacy. I don't want
kids. You you're to blame. Why are you
Why is Islam always a scapegoat? It's
always Islam. Look in the mirror. You're
the bloody fault. I prefer to live under
a Christian rule than to live in a
liberal rule as Islamically. Yeah.
Living with LGBTQ and trans and I'm a
piano and I'm a tree. I rather live
under the rule of at least there's some
commonalities. You're not doing that.
You've under your religion. Why are you
blaming Muslims and talking about
crusades? What does that mean by the
way?
>> Well, I mean the Crusades were a series
of wars that took place.
>> What's she trying to say?
>> Um that started in 1096.
I love you. You're magnifer
wars actually largely failures. Um I
would say
>> the species here.
>> So 1096 was the only really successful
you know crusade.
>> Thank you Derek.
>> Um and what happened with that one was
obviously that's when
>> I must say you're splendid today.
>> That's when too many hits on the head
there.
No, he's still going to
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, it was a failure. There was
about nine crusades altogether.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. And
>> when they eating, didn't they eat
Muslims? Yes. As part of the crusades.
Yeah. Uh I think you're right.
>> Maybe maybe you can give me exactly what
you're talking about. But I mean there
were nine crusades as I mentioned starts
on 1096. Uh the Muslims re recaptured in
the battle of uh some 88 years later.
Then you had the third crusade with
Richard obviously the lion heart and
Salahadin Leubi
but it was it was it was a it was a
failure all all around for the Christian
nation. Uh they weren't able to
>> uh recapture
>> uh Jerusalem ever again. They only
captured it once and so they they failed
time and time and time again. So I don't
know why you would want that to be
repeated. This is the actually one of
the weakest points of Christian history.
And the I think the key thing about the
crusade, yeah, that is relevant to us
and to our social discourse today is the
fact that when aubi went into and he
reconquered
uh Jerusalem,
>> he said to the Jews and Christians, you
can come to the land whenever you want.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. He literally said, you can come
whenever you want. This is an open place
for you. And he did not take revenge on
the people. Right.
>> Exactly. And even did when
>> but in 1096 when they took you know even
according to like I remember reading
Thomas I think Aspridge he was a teacher
of mine actually in university
>> and he wrote a book on the crusades. If
you any book that you aren't on the on
the crusades there's a book called the
crus you'll see that
>> um called the crusades. Yeah.
>> But uh you'll see that um when they came
in all right there was blood everywhere.
They were killing the men, women, and
children.
>> What's so g what is so excellent about
this point? Why are you showing off
about that? I wouldn't want I wouldn't
want to hide that. That's kind of ISIS
like I think that's what she that's
Christian ISIS kind of. I think it's
anti-semitic, bro. Cuz the crusaders
were known to slaughter the Jews.
>> Well, I mean, I would say um Yeah. Yeah.
Absolutely. The first time when they
went into Jerusalem, Yeah. they
slaughtered the Jews. Yeah, they did.
Yeah. What about the siege of Mahara
which occurred in 1098 in modern day
Syria? That was during the first
crusade. It is infamous for claims of
widespread cannibalism
by the crusaders.
>> No, the guys are barbarians. I mean,
let's be honest.
>> So is she. And that's the only thing.
The reason why is because you can't
intellectually deal with Islam.
>> And because of that, you have to go to
to the violence. Because why are you
talking about Christian? Why are you not
saying about intellectual? What happened
to turning the other cheek?
>> I as Christian it was a religion of
peace.
>> No, no, no. They say the there is no
turning other cheeks. Really? There's no
greater hatred than Christian love.
Okay, it's as simple as that. There is
no greater hatred than Christian love.
They love their enemies.
>> No, but yeah, but you know, she's not a
representative of majority of
Christians,
but the thing is she's obviously trying
to provoke us and she's trying to get us
angry and whatever and she's trying to
evoke a react cuz that's her brand. Her
brand is to say the most outrageous
thing. But the thing is, it's fine to be
outrageous and provocative or whatever.
It's fine. Okay, we all do it. No
problem. But just be accurate, okay?
Like the way you're trying to portray
the situation, right, is you're trying
to portray the Muslims as some kind of
like a takeover entity. We're an unarmed
minority in the United Kingdom that
represents 6% of the population.
>> There are more Christians in Egypt than
there are Muslims in Britain,
>> for example. Right.
>> Coptic Christians. Yeah, the Coptic
Christians are about 10 to 15%. We don't
see this like I'm originally Egyptian.
We don't see this kind of talk in Egypt.
You could obviously say they were there
before and that's a it's true. They were
there before the Muslims were there and
all that. I'm not making the point. I'm
making the point that
>> still there since
>> Yeah, they weren't wiped out actually by
the Muslims which shows you that Muslims
are not interested in genociding
>> Islam and there while Islam even
>> which is a proof of Islam's tolerance.
But putting that set aside like we don't
see this kind of thing. Why has the west
got this obsession
with minorities? Look, Bosnia, we've all
been to Bosnia before, right?
>> Uh you will know that people that are
coming from Croatia,
>> this a Christian country, they're going
into Bosnia. Okay? There's more
Croatians going into Bosnia than there
is Bosnians going into Croatia.
>> That's a Christians. Sometimes you have
more migrants from a Christian
neighboring nation going into a Muslim
majority country than the Malaysia,
another country, right?
You have Indians, Hindus going in there.
You have Chinese people going in there.
There's more Chinese and Indians going
into Malaysia than there is the opposite
of that.
>> So once again, why do we not see the
equivalent of this in Malaysia? And of
course, the Gulf countries are an easy
example, right?
>> Why have you Yeah. Dubai and the UAE and
the Gulf, Saudi Arabia,
>> immigrants are in the UAE, but it still
functions properly. Why? because they
have laws that work that people can
attest to. We we went to um a
supermarket in which there is a section
for haram food. There is
>> Yeah. Then you've got sections for
alcohol. They have their own system in
place. You don't see people moaning and
complaining and go, "Oh, we're going to
put some halal food there or we're going
to do this and you know it's this, it's
that." That's fine. You've got people
with different beliefs living amongst
you. You have an issue. It needs to be
dealt with.
>> But we don't have a farright problem
with these. Like we don't have Malaysian
farr rights that want to kick out the
Chinese. I haven't seen it. We haven't
seen the Bosnian farrights that want to
kick out the creations. But why do we
why do these people even exist in in the
UK? Why? What? The far right has become
such a a force now. All right. Why?
Because with all due respect, it's the
colonial legacy.
>> With all due respect, it's the white
supremacy. With all due respect, it's
it's the feeling of entitlement. It's
all that stuff.
And to be honest, it's become quite
boring now. They need to change the
script because it's getting too boring.
>> They're 40% of Christians are 40% of the
population. If you if you don't like the
fact that you have become minority in
your own lands after a,000 years, I
mean, Christianity came to this country
a thousand something years ago, right?
2,300 400 years ago.
>> And for the first time, it's actually a
minority in the religion since that
time. It's a minority religion. Well, if
you don't like that, then you're going
to have to do something about it. Who's
to blame?
>> It's not We don't care. It's not our
business. That is your problem, man. If
you're not taking your religion
seriously, you're not taking churches,
>> that's your problem. Pedophilia is your
problem. You've got white middle-aged
man. Who was that guy who um um abused
nearly 40 children out of the hundreds?
>> Stuart Leam. Evidences of him abusing
100 children.
>> Grooming. Grooming. Grooming. Yeah.
Absolutely. Exactly. This is your
problem. Don't blame us. You've got this
problem.
>> Keep blaming us for everything.
>> Exactly. You know, it's like, you know,
if something falls on your head, you're
going to say it was Islam. You know, you
know when you say, you know, when you
say, "Oh, Christianity is going down.
Why? Because the Muslims are taking
over." It's not one or the other. You
have a center group of a growing
minority, which is atheists and
agnostics. It's not that, oh, Muslims
are taking all of them. No, you have
people that are literally falling into
no man's land, and your argumentation is
simply too weak and your ability to
bring them in. Your evangelizing skills
are too extreme. Even when you look at
speaker corner, most of your guys are
aligning with the far right than they
are just aligning with the right wing.
They are comfortable with becoming
extremists rather than just portraying
their religion in its pure and pristine
form because surely if it's pure and
pristine, it should affect one's innate
disposition and it doesn't. Islam does.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And that's what it And
that's why even Tom Robinson when we
went to the march where we got attacked
he was appeasing to the the left as the
trans he had trans on there trans people
on there then then his huligans attacked
him and said why you getting these
people now he's appealing to the
conservative because you have no
foundations it's the left it's the right
whoever is against Islam you have no
foundations you done a march where
apparently 100 3 million you can forget
that 100,000 plus people came no problem
what did you do you came and the next
day you go to eating bacon drinking
alcohol having sex outside of marriage
not going to church where's your
foundation you have nothing that's why
you Islam. She admitted Islam is a
superpower. And what did she do instead
of admitting that? She said, "Oh,
because they're having kids." And said,
"Shut up, man. Shut up. You have
nothing. If
>> if we're going to admit anything, we
should admit that the superpower of the
world militarily is United States of
America."
>> And that doesn't matter because that's
>> and and Muslims are not going to take
over. She was talking about Dearborn and
these kinds of places. Muslims are not
even what 1% of the United States
population. Look at the army they've
got. Look at the nuclear weapons they've
got. Look at the economy they have.
Muslims have no they don't even factor
into that
>> this nuclear weapon it's not and it's
not good analogy in the sense but it's
we have the Quran
>> we have foundations
>> and that's what we fall on let me tell
you something that is the thing that you
fear the most you know why because even
Tommy Robinson says this they're
brainwashing our youngsters no my friend
we're just giving dow we're inviting
people and you fear that and that is
something you can't deal with that's why
you're bugging up because all we're
doing is now they're bugging out
>> and people are coming to Islam bro in
Dubai alone 10,000 thousand people. I've
met four of them.
>> I went and met these reverts because of
the Salah Pro project. Bro, I'm telling
you,
>> these are blonde women like Sister
Kirsty, Sister Andrea, Brother Josh,
Scott. We met them. Yeah,
>> bro. You will look go past them. You
will never think this a Muslim. We met
Sister Kirsty.
>> She doesn't wear hijab. She's been to
Umra, she wakes up. She prays, bro. I
don't pray, bro, bro. She prays. Her
religion. I'm looking, bro. Would we
ever think she's a Muslim,
>> brother? She she's more close to Allah
than I am.
>> And this is the dean. That's That's easy
to achieve as well.
>> Well, on that bombshell, we'll leave it
as that. And inshallah, if you want to
watch the fight, it's the uh 11th of
October, Saturday the 11th of October.
Click the link below.
Hey, you are you wasting your time on
social media again? Your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a masid, a da center.
Establishing a masid to convey the
message of Islam is one of the best
deeds a Muslim can do. There's a huge
need for it in Norway. You know this and
I know this. So that makes the reward
even greater. So give generously and
Allahawel will give you even more.